ん
me
べジフアーティスト
why ベジフルアーティス
なぜ
僕はベジフルアーティストと言ってるでしょ
野菜ソムリエという食のプロの資格を持って仕事をしています
野菜や果物のことが本当に大好きです
ただもう一つ僕には好きなものがあります
それは
えお
タックということです
今出てるへ
トマトとかキャベツブロッコリ
たくさんの野菜が地球という器に入っているイラストです
そしてそこには言葉を添えています
無意識を意識すれば可能性が広がる
僕の絵には必ずイラストと
言葉が入っています
実はこの絵ですちょうど今から1年前
2016年の2月の初日の朝に買いたいです
前の日にお会いした方からインスピレーションを受けた
印象で書いた絵になります
この様だよ
僕は毎日1枚必ず書くようにしています
それが
積み重なって1613前
今日で160013日目になります
始まったのは2012年の9月の僅か
今年で4年半ぐらいですね
今日は
皆さんに
続けるということですね大雪さん
そしてなぜ僕が絵を書き始めたのか
そして書き続けて私が感じたこと
嬉しいな楽しいなと思ったことそれをみなさんにシェアしたいなと思っています
これは私が続けてきている絵の一部です
ただ
僕人生で一番苦手なことがあるんです
それは何かというと続けるということです
人生で5回転職しています
ダイエットもつい先日3キロ痩せた良かったと思ってちょっと気を抜いたらね
ゴキをリボンでしましたそんな感じでなかなかでこう続けるって言うのは難しい
その中でこの絵をかくことっていうのは続いてるわけなんですがそれには一つの
きっかけとなる言葉がありました
それはこんな言葉です
人のやらないことをやり続けること
なんか不思議に思いませんなんでこの言葉にカレーの絵なのかなと
この言葉を
まあ授けてくれた方っていうのが皆さんもねよく食べられている方もいらっしゃるかも
しれません
もうカレーチェーン店の
社長の言葉だったんですね
はどんな言葉だったんでしょうそれはこんな言葉でした
その彼朝4時半に出社してそして
最大800店舗もある遠方から来るお客様の声に一つ一つ目を通してコメントをします
それを9時までに終わらせて朝の9時から10時まで
毎日お店の外掃除
雨が降っても風が吹いても雪が降っても続けました
そして10時からは自分の仕事を全うつ
彼は言います
早起きをすること
書類に目を通すことそして奏上することを自分の仕事は全うすること
どれ一つとっても特別なことをやっていませんと
ただ
このことを26年間
続けたことは私以外に出来ませんと言われたんですね
その話を聞いではかっけーなーと思ったんです
なんかね僕にもそんな誰でもできるけど
続けていくと特別になるまあそんなことができないかなと思いました
それが僕にとっては絵を書くことだったんですね
それが積み重なって1600枚を超えてたくさんの絵を書いています
まぁ色々書いているともう全てに思い出が集まっていて本当にたくさんの子どものよう
な存在です
その中から今日は
一つこの柄を選んでみました
言の葉というね
えです
真木は書いて字の通り言の葉です葉っぱです
僕のされている言葉皆さんの話している言葉
みんな言葉ですことの葉っぱちょっと想像してみてください
体という感じ
人は1本のキっと書いてからだ
そうなんですぼくたちわたしたちの体というのは1本の木でできています
その木から生まれるものそれが葉っぱです
言葉という
違う生み出す葉っぱそれが私たちが話す言葉です
毎日続けてきて言葉と絵を踏むいできて感じたことがあります
それは今まで見えなかったものが
見えてきたこと
まあ決してねあのおばけが見えるとかそういうスピリチュアルな話ではないんですか
あのう今まで
視界には入ってたけど気づかなかったということですね
例えば小さなお花だったりお子さんの笑顔だったり疎遠に飛んでるチョウチョがね
綺麗だなとか感じたりそういう日は普通の日常のことがすごく幸せなことだと感じる
ようになったんですね
僕はずーっと
40年過ぎて a
幸せっていうことに
無頓着でした
幸せというのは死ぬまで手に届かないものじゃないかなと思っていました
いつも生きも遠くにあって手が届かない
死ぬ時になって幸せっていうのが感じられるのか
もしかしたら死ぬまで幸せというのは感じられないんじゃないかなと思った時もあり
ましたでも
こうして毎日毎日書き続けることで気づいたことがあります
幸せというのは今ここにあるもんだなと
当たり前と思っていることに感謝するそのことだけで
今ここにいることだけでそれだけで幸せなんだと思うようになりました
ここで
初めて打ち合わせをさせていただいたときいっぱいのカプ厨をいただきました
美味しいカプチーノを飲みながらそしていろんな話をさせていただきました
その
日の次に書いた絵がこんな言葉です
カプチーノからハートがね飛び出て今ここ幸せという言葉を描かせていただきました
本当に
今降雪付けてきて毎日毎日
8言葉を鼓で紡いできて感じること
ここに存在していること自体が幸せ今日皆さんの前でこうして話せることも幸せに関し
ています
たくさんの方と今日はお会いできますし
いろんな映像を通じて見ていただけると思います
ここに
この時間を共有できているみなさんに感謝を申し上げたいと思います皆さんも幸せを
ぜひ感じてください
そして最後に野菜ソムリエ大亮のペースたブルー
no life ありがとうございました yeah a
ありがとうございます
[拍手]